the country community is about unity and
love and having a great time
and they kind of stay out of the
politics a lot but
race is not a political statement it is
an actual just a human right statement
[Music]
period
is the message that you want fans to
take away
from this new music i just want them you
know
there's so much going on in the world
that so
often we just you know sweep under a rug
and just hope it goes away but in this
album like i actually address some of
the issues but not only do i address it
i give a message of hope like that's
what i want people to feel i want people
to feel first of all seen
i want people to feel heard and then i
want them to feel hope and that's really
what this
this um ep is about you've always been
very vocal
uh when it comes to a lot of injustices
whether it's racial whether
it's the lack of females on country
radio and just the way that women are
treated
in the country music industry i mean
people who have followed you for years
know that about you that
you won't stop calling out those
injustices
why is that important for you well it's
so important to me because as a woman
as a black woman i know what it feels
like to be unseen
so it is so important for me to for
people to feel
seen and that they know that someone has
their back
and me being in this music industry and
knowing firsthand
what discrimination feels like and then
to see
women in country music that are white
dealing with discrimination like it's so
difficult and i
cannot sit there and not say anything
yeah it would completely be absolutely
wrong if i didn't so i just always want
women and marginalized people no matter
what color you are
to know like i will always stand up for
what is right period
do you feel the tide changing at all for
not only
women in country music but also black
artists and country music
there's still not nearly as many women
that i want to see on the charts
and country radio but i know it also
takes a very long time to get a single
up the radio
charts now because it is so crowded but
i am
seeing more women getting number ones
and that is a win so whether the victory
is big or small you have to celebrate it
i'm seeing more
women of color getting chances at
getting record deals and
getting publishing deals and that is
also a big deal again is it a big
number of people no but the fact that
it's happening you have to celebrate
that so yeah i am seeing a change
i feel like this new music is going to
be healing for a lot of people
there was a lot of support in nashville
in the country music industry in
particular
what would you say was the most
surprising
thing for you to see and to hear coming
out of nashville during that time
it is not a natural thing for country
musicians to really step out and take a
stance like that it's just
that is not something that the country
music community does like
the country community is about unity and
love
and having a great time and they kind of
stay out of the
politics a lot and so but race
is not a political statement it is an
actual just a human rights statement
period
and to see so many artists step up that
day
i was scared more people were going to
be silent but there were way more people
and way more artists
that stepped up and were like racism is
not accepted in this country
and is not accepted in this community
and that meant so much to me
because if when you didn't say anything
that means i don't matter
and i'm in this community and i that
showed that i matter to these people
and it just was so important what are
your
thoughts heading into the election this
november and why is voting important for
you
voting is important because our
forefathers
people that when we weren't even a
thought were fighting for those
rights for an example like black people
back in the 1800s we're not even
considered a full person
and what those people went through what
our ancestors went there for
us to be given the opportunity to vote
what the women's suffrage
movement went through so that we could
vote
what our veterans went through so that
we could vote
and have freedom it's so important for
you to take that stance and take your
vote
seriously so no matter what party you
vote for it is
none of my business but go to the poll
and use your right use your
constitutional right to vote it is
so important make your voice heard and
make it hurt your voice matters 100
except the trolls on instagram and
twitter that i've seen
that i see commenting to you all the
time their voice
no but you know what when you want to
display your racism i will gladly give
you the
platform to do so what do you hope
changes
from this and how can we make social
media a healthier environment
what if we use social media to uplift
people
and to incite change like what if we all
used our social media for that
versus making it just all about
ourselves and
for me when i get trolls that
say awful things to me it would be very
easy for me to block it would be very
easy for me to
throw stones back but instead of
throwing stones i try to
be very thoughtful in my response to
them
and then also show the world like
when i tell you that i deal with racism
on an
everyday basis it's not something i make
up in my head
it literally is in my instagram
on a daily and my twitter on an almost
daily basis so i will post it just so
people can see
and educate like education is key with
all of that being said how do you make
sure that
you are maintaining your mental health
well you know i have a great
you know home base my husband is very
very supportive of me and
also to be honest i quit drinking almost
a year ago
um for personal reasons just because it
was getting out of control nashville
really gets you in that drinking phase
but i quit drinking
and honestly that has helped my mental
morale
the most out of everything it has really
like there's that voice in your head
that feeds you those lies of shame and
these horrible things about yourself and
when i quit drinking
that voice is gone so that has helped my
mental health
songwriting has helped my mental health
writing about what's going on in the
world today
it has been really like therapy for me
it really helps me
just get it out and then i can move
forward and then i have a lot of fur
animals all around my house i'm sure
you've heard them shaking and running
about
but i didn't see the computer i did see
the screen move a little bit
yes they're everywhere let me tell you
but they often help me
i love that you have a good solid
support system there that's that's
amazing i wanted to ask you about
performing at the acm
first of all congratulations that's
amazing i'm so
excited for you do you know what you're
performing yet or what the details are
yes so i will be performing what are you
going to tell her can you look her in
the face
[Music]
it is going to be just such a beautiful
heartfelt
performance because again racism
is such a huge pandemic but also the
treatment of women
is just as big of a pandemic and it is
so important
for me to stand on that stage and to
sing a song
that represents there's not a single
woman that i don't know
that hasn't gone through something and i
just want hope that this song
and people hearing me sing it inspires
change that we protect our future
daughters like we are adults
but what can we do to prevent that from
happening to the future
it is up to us and i hope this song
gives everybody that
um that fire within them
to to change to help make change for our
future